hi i'm michael urie i play peter and i'm
philemon chambers i play nick and we are
the cast of single all the way and we're
here today with buzzfeed to see how well
we got to know each other on set let's
see
[Music]
their favorite snack at crafty
swedish fish
it means i got it right no not at all
it's not swedish fish no who's swedish
fish you vegan no it's the only thing
vegan at peanut butter no that's that's
an incomplete answer no not true because
you would just take the peanut butter
things and just eat them by yours
no
with
crackers
wait so what's your favorite snack chia
pudding oh chia pudding what's yours
peanut butter and banana oh okay i was
close that's like a partial credit he
can have fun he can have partial credit
their dressing room
must have
i'm gonna go
with the
mp3 player music um
a pull-out bed
that would be correct
i do like a nap i do like a map am i not
correct yes you are right because you
know i love my music their go-to
activity between filming scenes
social media okay okay yeah but also too
you check your phone after takes in
between stuff so but it's not social
media you just text everybody back is
that what i'm doing or is there
something else that i'm doing on my
phone
i feel like it's that i feel like you
just oh
yeah no i'm still gonna stick with like
messaging people back i play crossword
puzzles
the person who visited the most on set
oh this is a sad one
nobody
covered nobody literally
couldn't do anything
their favorite scene you shot together
[Music]
the ending you think that was my
favorite scene that we shot together i
mean i did until you kind of said it
like that
yeah it was yeah yeah that one it's my
favorite it's my favorite yeah their
favorite movie the lion king two this is
information i've recently learned and i
regret not true remember go back to the
question what is it i tell people
something's my favorite movie but this
is actually my favorite movie
oh right so so
so nope you're wrong too neither of us
got it right
philemon tells people that the lion king
part one is his favorite movie
but it's actually
mac and me and
when asked his favorite it's not mac and
me wrong again
harry and the henderson oh harry and
henderson's okay that's better than mac
and me
what is yours my favorite movie that i
tell people is arthur right but it's
actually batman
their favorite holiday song ariana
grande
it's not no
no what is it um it would be faith hill
where are you christmas all right what's
mine
kermit singing merry christmas what
that's not even a christmas carol i
don't know because christmas isn't even
a song britney
now
now
yeah there's a song called now no like
britney now like you know like now at
this moment in time are you speaking
english it's all i want for christmas is
you basic
i'm basic
the first time
you met zoom zoom zoom zoom chemistry
chemistry read on zoom which is like
really super nice their birth year your
birth year is gonna get it right 1996.
no three no five
no four yeah 1994 1980.
i'm good their birthday august 19th
incorrect i thought it is august 19th
it's august the 8th
well i have no idea what your birthday
is what is february 9th february 9th
aquarius their hometown los angeles
compton correct texas that's a state i
know
i don't think you told me your hometown
oh didn't i no
no i'm sure that never came up i don't
think so in six weeks of working i don't
think it's side by side i don't think as
friends and lovers give me it and then
i'll see if i remember it plano texas no
i would remember that would you have i
would have because it sounds funny their
middle name
is it your middle name philemon yes
do you have a middle name i do i never
knew it really no i've never known it
i've never asked because i didn't care i
don't care now
what is your middle name lorenzo lorenzo
that's right michael lorenzo
that sounds good their coffee order
chai
no you don't eat you know like chai no
how do you take your coffee with a lot
of cream that's it i don't i just got
back on drinking coffee yeah
literally i didn't drink coffee you
didn't drink coffee when you worked
together you didn't either we drove no i
did i drink coffee in the morning oh
yeah another character
they've portrayed mark ugly betty mark
ugly betty um isn't that it well his
name was mark yeah yeah
guy and
short film
marcus his name is marcus marcus i knew
you were in a short film yeah you got
that one their hidden talent hidden
i'm like
that implies
i think your hidden talent is
taking thirst traps so how much i love
you that's right um
i feel like yours
just how lovely you are that's a hidden
talent isn't it oh
now we click show me my results
that's not great oh yeah i got seven i
got nine wow i got nine you can catch
single all the way on netflix right now
go why are you still here watch it
watching us watch the movie
you